lawmakers unveil bipartisan bill that
aims to ban Tick Tock for the U.S okay
for government agencies right yeah so
here we go the new bill introduced by
Senator Marco Rubio Republican and
representative Mike Gallagher from
Wisconsin Republican Raja krishima
morthy Democrat Illinois would ban all
transactions from any social media
company in or under the influence of
China Russia and several other foreign
countries of concern the anti-social
ccpt act which stands for averting the
national threat of Internet surveillance
oppressive censorship and influence an
algorithmic learning by the Chinese
Communist Party explicitly named bike
dance and Tick Tock as subject to the
restrictions in the bill unless and
until the date on which the president
certifies to Congress that the company
no longer meets any of the conditions
described such as being subject to
substantial influence by country of
concern so we we called this a while ago
on the podcast tick tock's got a a
life's you know timeline before they're
going to be off I even made a video
about Tick Tock that just went up number
one on the channel tell us about that
video yeah the video I just gave data I
just broke it down I said listen the day
August 5th of this year I made a video
trashing China okay in the control that
they want over America all this other
stuff from that moment uh 720 views
videos later at a 720 uploads on Tick
Tock only two one over a hundred
thousand views weird and if you go back
and look at 264 prior to that how many
won over a hundred thousand views on 264
720 96 went over I don't know what the
number was 90 some big number nine one
over a million we have the data on here
to show it and those same Clips the 720
that didn't go on Tick Tock that didn't
go viral on other accounts went viral on
other Tick Tock accounts went viral but
then on Instagram been viral but not on
Tick Tock now here's the thing this is
what's crazy about I don't know if you
saw this one go all the way to the top
the moment the video went live yesterday
look what happened to some of the clips
yesterday zoom in zoom in zoom in zoom
in the moment I uploaded the video 31.8
000 that wasn't the case 22.7 000 keep
going left to show 49 keep going 13 8 9
54 164. this hasn't happened for 720
videos wow the the level of manipulation
that Tick Tock has
with what they're doing some people said
well I thought you were all about
Freedom you know what is this about
banning companies and all this other
stuff I thought capitalists and
Republicans and all this stuff were all
about freedom and Libertarians are all
about Freedom yeah except if the enemy
is using a technology to divide and
dummify your people that is the enemy
you are naive if you think and so all
these Patriot Act that we have that are
spying on America fine I'm more
comfortable having my own country spy on
us than I have with a China our number
one enemy spying on us I don't want
anybody spying on anybody period but
it's definitely not going to be the
Enemy of the State number one which is
China the RT but we banned when Russia
went to war with uh Ukraine they banned
RT News the app is you can't even go on
it and what they're doing and Adam I
think you said it to the last podcast I
was on with you guys that it's the youth
they're brainwashing and ruining the
youth and the other through them that
they're getting from everybody's phone
from where you go what you do what you
buy where these young kids are going and
then giving them all these challenges
making them stupid in China you can't
even it's all educational stuff yeah
Andrew Schultz you got to give him
credit he was the one that kind of made
that very popular he's basically saying
what they show in China versus what they
show here in the States but for me the
thing with Tick Tock is this everything
comes down to risk and reward what's the
reward with Tick Tock you get to see
some dance videos you get to see some
stuff all right it's cool it's fun
what's the risk this is a full-on
national security threat you kind of
went down the line of what they're doing
they're tracking your phone movements
they're tracking everything
this is not something we want here in
America I don't know how long Tick Tock
is going to be here but I'm a full
advocate of getting this out of here
apparently imagine question is it what
is it about China that from the Wuhan
lab to all this [ __ ] to tick tock we
don't make no like move like I think
Trump was the only anti-china tax you
know the tariffs the trades what is it
why don't we pull the trigger just
because we owe them all this money we
can't do [ __ ]
you remember when I said a bunch of
things got banned they waited until
after midterms to do it there's no way
you're going to do a tick tock before
election midterm yeah because most of
the people on Tick Tock are progressive
did you hear what shank said on tweet he
tweeted something chunky said yeah he
said the he says look what they're doing
with Tick Tock Banning Tick Tock most
Progressive people who are going viral
are on Tick Tock and now they're taking
that voice away now he's a socialist
hardcore Progressive so he is saying the
fact that Tick Tock was a great tool for
him
now they're taking that down and he's
right because Tick Tock was doing a lot
of stuff right there politics is so
predictable Tick Tock has by far the
most Progressive content of any platform
both Republicans and corporate Democrats
hate Progressive so look at what they're
looking to shut down now Tick Tock so
he's right the progressive Camp they
don't want Tick Tock to be going down
and so you don't do that before you do
it now got you it's just a matter of
time by the way guess who's doing
backflips Twitter Twitter's doing better
yeah the moment this thing gets done so
what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetaining it says future looks bright
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red or black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people wore it in
the office they had to order 58 of them
because people wanted the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future looks spread toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
[Music]